whether it's working on a classic
Stephen King movie or one of his more
frowned upon films getting involved with
the king of horror can make a star
revive a career or to give an actor a
new perspective from helpful psychics to
horrified housewives these King roles
have changed these actors forever
Anthony Michael Hall was one of the
biggest young stars of the 1980s a
regular actor for teen movie director
John Hughes a veteran of the vacation
franchise and a brief cast member of
Saturday Night Live his career seemed
bulletproof then came the 90s and halls
career seriously tapered off he spent
most of the decade doing guest TV
appearances and showing up in less
successful movies
Paul is at a professional low in 2001 he
co-starred and Freddy got fingered and
critics had some pretty harsh things to
say about the film it shocks a year
later he managed to snag the lead role
in a TV show based on Stephen King's
book the dead zone for six seasons Paul
played the part of Johnny Smith a man
who wakes up from a coma with psychic
powers during its run the dead zone was
one of the highest-rated shows on basic
cable after years of mrs. Hall had a hit
again and he's credited the dead zone
with turning his career around if
Shelley Duvall's performance as a woman
driven to the edge of sanity and The
Shining seems like an authentic
depiction of terror it's because it is
director Stanley Kubrick was a noted
perfectionist and his demanding style
made her very emotional on set one shot
famously took at 127 takes allegedly in
part because Kubrick wanted to push
Duvall to the point of breaking down
even though shooting the film was by all
accounts a horrible experience Duval's
performance was so memorable she soon
became a very well-known actor she told
People magazine in 1981 when somebody
recognizes you at a Dairy Queen in Texas
you're a star after the torturous
atmosphere of the shining Duvall was
more than happy to star opposite the
kind-hearted Robin Williams in her next
role that of olive oil and Robert
Altman's Popeye not many films can boast
a cast like Stand By Me fewer films can
claim to be the starting point for no
less than four successful acting careers
based on Stephen King's novella the body
stand by me tells the story of four boys
searching for corpse in the woods and
the four kids in question were played by
new teenage actors will we
Jerry O'Connell Corey Feldman and River
Phoenix as for Wil Wheaton stand by me
was his first major movie role and he
joined the cast of Star Trek The Next
Generation soon after he since gone on
to become something of a geek icon
epitomized by playing a version of
himself on the Big Bang Theory it was
also the first movie role of Jerry
O'Connell who would go on to a solid
acting career on stage and screen with
perhaps his most prominent role being in
the cast of the sci-fi show sliders
Corey Feldman was the most established
star and stand by me having already
appeared in gremlins and The Goonies but
he continued to be extremely successful
for the rest of the decade although his
career peaked in the 80s Feldman had
already amassed an impressive body of
work and definitely made the most of his
time in the spotlight and only young
once yeah but you're gonna be stupid for
the rest of your life and of course
there's River Phoenix whose work in the
film helped sell it to weary
distributors coming out of this movie he
was pegged as the next big thing he
acted in several high-profile movies
including Indiana Jones in the Last
Crusade and my own Private Idaho before
his tragic death by overdose at the
young age of 23 although more
experienced than many of his fellow cast
members stand by me also featured a
breakout performance from another
fresh-faced Kiefer Sutherland who had
become a major star just a year later
with his role in The Lost Boys Morgan
Freeman the actor is a huge star
but Morgan Freeman the voice is arguably
even more well-known as a performer his
calm but authoritative demeanor has seen
him play everyone from a humble
chauffeur and Driving Miss Daisy to God
himself and Bruce Almighty as a narrator
he's voiced over everything from
oscar-winning documentaries like march
of the Penguins
to the Discovery Channel's curiosity and
his career as a voice-over artist can be
traced back to a Stephen King role the
inmate bread in the Shawshank Redemption
based on a novella from the King
collection different seasons the 1994
film had Freeman pulling double-duty not
only was he one of the main characters
but he also narrated the entire movie
and delivered some of its most iconic
lines
I hope the Pacific is as blue as a
in my dreams I hope while the shawshank
redemption' bombed financially in
theaters it picked up a second life on
TV and in the rental market eventually
becoming a massively beloved film for
fans around the world many years later
Freeman was a guest on Graham Norton's
talk show and he poked a little fun at
his reputation as a master of narration
I hope people stop asking me to do
stupid voiceovers
[Music]
check out one of our newest videos right
here
Plus even more looper videos about your
favorite actors are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]